هذه الاخبار العاجله التي وردت بحسب مراسل
الجزيره اذا قصف يستهدف مقرا للحشد الشعبي
شرق العاصمه العراقيه بغداد ايضا مصادر في
الشرطه العراقيه تحدثت في وكاله رويترز عن
مقتل اثنين على الاقل من مقاتلي فصائل
الحشد الشعبي وجرح خمسه اخرين ايضا مصدر
في الحشد الشعبي يقول القصف الذي سدف احد
مقارنا شرق بغداد نفذته طائرات يعتقد انها
امريكيه للمتابعه معنا من بغداد مدير مكتب
الجزيره سامر يوسف سامر ضعنا لو سمحت اولا
فيما يتعلق بالبيانات الصادره سواء من
الاطراف اطراف الحشد الشعبي او من وزاره
الداخليه
العراقيه بدايه نشوان المصادر تتحدث
بالفعل عن مقتل شخص ومن ثم بعد دقائق تاكد
مقتل شخص اخر هذه المصادر من الحشد الشعبي
المقر الذي وصف يقع في منطقه شارع فلسطين
شرق العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد نفذ القصف بحسب مصادر في
الحجد الشعبي بواسطه طائره مسيره يعتقدون
بانها طائره امريكيه تاتي هذه الهجمات
اي بحسب ما يعتقد ايضا ا المصدر في الحشد
الشعبي ردا على استهداف معسكرات او قواعد
تتواجد فيها القوات الامريكيه في مناطق
مختلفه من البلاد ان كان في قاعده عين
الاسد الانبار غربي العراق او حتى القواعد
الامريكيه في سوريا في اقليم كردستان
العراق في الشمال العراقي تحديدا قاعده
حرير والمعسكر في داخل مطار اربيل هناك في
عاصمه اقليم كردستان هذه الهجمات
ليست الاولى التي تستهدف مقرات تابعه
للحشد الشعبي او الفص
صائل العراقيه قبل ايام من الان كانت هناك
ثلاثه هجمات نفذت ايضا بواسطه طائرات
مسيره امريكيه تبنتها بالفعل الولايات
المتحده صريح العباره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي هذه الهجمات
مقرات او استهدفت مقرات لحد الشعبي وفصائل
عراقيه مسلحه تنضوي تحت مسمى المقاومه
الاسلاميه في العراق في محافظات
وواسط وتسببت بمقتل شخص واحد على الاقل
على اثر هذه الهجمات
واصلت المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق وهي
مجموعه من الفصائل العراقيه المسلحه
هجمات مقار معسكرات
تابعه قوات التحالف الولي كما تقول
الحكومه العراقيه وهي تتواجد فيها قوات
امر امريكيه او كما تصفها الحكومه
العراقيه مستشارين امنيين للتحالف الدولي
يقدمون الدعم لل القوات العراقيه كل هذه
الاجواء نشوان بطبيعه الحال هي ارتدادات
للحرب على غزه وفي غزه الهجمات التي
تنفذها المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق على
معسكرات او قواعد امريكيه في البلاد او
حتى في سوريا هي نصره لاهل غز كما تذيل
بياناتها المقاومه العراقيه بهذه العباره
وبانها ستستمر بهذه الهجمات التي لا تقتصر
فقط مؤخرا على القواعد الامريكيه او
التواجد الامريكي في سوريا والعراق انما
حتى وصلت الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه
واستهدفت عصب
اقتصادي اسرائيلي مهم وهو حقل كيرش الغازي
في البحر الابيض المتوسط هذه الهجمات
ستستمر بحسب المقاومه في العراق حتى ايقاف
العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه كما تقول
الفصا الشقيه المسلحه وتنطلق من وحده صف
المقاومه في مختلف البلاد ان كان في اليمن
او لبنان وحتى في العراق اي نحن اي نحاول
الوصول الى هذا المقر الذي تم استهدافه
يقال بحسب المصادر ايضا بانه مقر للدعم
اللوجستي ولكن ايضا مصادر اخرى تتحدث عن
مقتل شخصيه مهمه في الحشد الشعبي او احد
قاده حركه النجباء المنضوي في الحشد
الشعبي بطبيعه الحال ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
لا معلومات مؤكده بهذا الخصوص وبالتالي
سامر هل يخشى من ان يتسع تتسع دائره
الصراع فيما يتعلق ب الطرفين هنا الامريكي
كقوات اجنبيه موجوده بغطاء حكومي ب بغطاء
برلماني وايضا هذه الاطراف في الحشد
الشعبي والتي من ضمنها اطراف مشاركه في في
الحكومه
طبعا اذا ما استندنا الى بيانات الفصائل
العراقيه منفرده او مجتمعه تحت مسمى
المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق فهذه
الهجمات مرتبطه ارت باطا وثيقا باحداث غزه
بالحرب على وفي قطاع غزه توقفت هذه
الهجمات لايام قليله نشوان تزامنا مع
الهدنه التي حصلت في غزه في نوفمبر الماضي
ولكن استؤنفت مجددا عندما استؤنف القتال
تربط المقاومه الاسلاميه عملياتها هذه
بالحرب على غزه
لتخلص من ما تصفه المحتل الامريكي في
البلاد واخراج القوات الامريكيه الفصائل
العراقيه هنا لا تؤمن
بفكره المستشارين الامنيين المتواجدين من
التحالف الدولي داخل البلاد هي متاكده
بحسب بياناتها بان التواجد الامريكي هنا
هو تواجد قتالي لقوات امريكيه في داخل
الاراضي العراقيه في قواعد تسيطر عليها
القوات الامريكيه وليس مستشارين هذا ما
تنفيه الحكومه الحكومه
ايضا تدين بشده الهجمات التي
تستهدف ان كانت السفاره الامريكيه او حتى
القواعد التي تتواجد فيها القوات قوات
التحالف الدولي او القوات
الامريكيه تقول بان من ينفذ هذه الهجمات
هم جماعات خارجه عن القانون هي تحاول ضبط
الوضع داخليا ولكن يبدو بان الامر ليس
سهلا مع استمرار هذه الهجمات ومع استمرار
الرد الامريكي للمره الثانيه في داخل
المدن هذا اليوم كما شهدناه في منطقه
حيويه
اي مهمه جدا بالنسبه للعاصمه العراقيه
بغداد داخل احياء سكنيه يكون هذا المقر
للدعم اللوجستي تم استهدافه اليوم اشكرك
سامر يوسف مدير مكتب الجزيره من بغداد
حدتنا عبر الهاتف